Marvel's Avengers infinity war packed a
lot of characters and a lot of plot into
it's nearly three hour runtime with all
the character names subplots
and relationships that fans had to keep
straight it's no surprise there were
some Easter eggs that flew over
audiences heads here are a few small
details you might have missed in
Avengers infinity war nothing goes over
my head my reflexes are too fast
nebula disassembled nebulas torture at
the hands of Thanos is one of the more
gruesome parts of the movie and a
reference to the Infinity Gauntlet comic
arc that provides the inspiration for
much of the film while the movie
showcases nebula strung up like a damien
hirst exhibit the comic series features
Thanos reducing her to a brain-dead
zombie like form but still pretty much
keeping her on display for company her
eventual counter-attack leads to her
possessing the Infinity Gauntlet which
she uses to restore the lives that vanos
ended don't be surprised if she has a
big role in restoring the lives of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes next year
ultimate Thor when Thor returns to earth
with his new hammer Stormbreaker
it's a thrilling moment for comic fans
and audience members alike what some
fans might not have noticed is that the
visuals of Thor's return are straight
out of The Ultimates comic series both
the glowing bulbs of his vest and his
axe like hammer are pulled directly from
the ultimate universe of Marvel Comics
here's hoping that the new weapon fares
a bit better than Thor's old hammer
cap versus Stannis dawn of just us
there's plenty of moments in the
Infinity Gauntlet comics that aren't
adapted for infinity war but there's one
moment in the comic series that
absolutely had to be adapted Captain
America facing down Thanos after
watching him beat down the strongest
heroes in the Marvel Universe without
breaking a sweat it's a character
defining moment for Steve Rogers is the
last Avenger standing and the spirit of
that moment makes it into infinity war
beautifully colorblind vision in
infinity war when Thanos finally rips
the mind stone out of visions head his
body immediately loses coloring visions
newly colorless body is pulled straight
from the comics specifically West Coast
Avengers after getting his programming
white vision returned to functionality
as a fully colorless much less emotional
hero than he had been infinity Wars
reference to vision losing color after
getting his mind destroyed is likely an
indication that even if vision gets
resurrected with some of his teammates
he probably won't be the same robot that
fans know and love
I'm not javis I know I am 17 a protocol
when Tony Stark orders the 17 a protocol
it gives Peter Parker the high-tech iron
spider outfit that Spidey uses to great
effect
it's crowd-pleasing moment but the quick
reference to spider-man and the number
17 might have left well read comic fans
a bit nervous in spider-man number 17
Peter Parker gets killed while trying to
save a woman and her daughter from a vat
of exploding freon in the afterlife
Spidey meets Thanos and his beloved lady
death after a struggle death takes pity
on spider-man and the young girl he
failed to save allowing them to come
back to life like in the comic Spidey
doesn't survive through infinity war but
it's likely he'll come back in the
sequel since comic books rarely keep
anyone off the pages for long that's a
lot packed into Abe Lincoln you'll miss
it reference the doctor is in trouble
early in the film Doctor Strange is
captured by a Bini ma who tortures dr.
strange with energy
it's a haunting interaction and you
might have guessed it's another one
that's inspired by the comics in this
case the very personal relationship was
featured in infinity a modern-day sequel
to Infinity Gauntlet that likewise
served as a major inspiration for
infinity war Hulk in a strange land one
of the movie's most striking visuals is
Hulk getting teleported to earth to warn
Doctor Strange in the rest of the MCU
heroes that Thanos is coming while it's
a great way to showcase Thanos his
indomitable power early in the film it's
also taken right from the original
Infinity Gauntlet comics in the comics
though it's the Silver Surfer who gets
launched into dr. Strange's sanctum
there's a deeper reason behind that swap
of characters than just rights issues
and Hulk being the strongest one there
is
Hulk Doctor Strange and Silver Surfer
are often contemporaries in the comics
as part of a super team the defenders so
it's not a stretch to substitute one for
the other white wolf if you miss the
reference at the end of Black Panther
then Avengers infinity war wants to make
sure that you heard right Bucky gets
referred to as the white wolf by touch
Allah when they're preparing to fight
Thanos in the comics hunter the white
wolf is wakanda's spymaster as well as
two challahs caucasian adopted brother
with Infinity Ward doubling down on the
reference it looks likely that they're
establishing that Bucky will have a
place in Wakanda as a spy following the
conclusion of the battle against Thanos
if he survives that is ambiguous ending
Avengers infinity war ends with Danno
swiping out half the universe smiling
contentedly after accomplishing his
goals interestingly enough that ending
is a direct mirror to the original
ending of Infinity Gauntlet
although the comic segment comes after
Thanos defeats at the hands of Adam
warlock at most of the Marvel Universe
it's a surprisingly sympathetic ending
showing the mad Titan at peace with
himself having had and lost ultimate
power and choosing instead to live as a
humble farmer with no higher aspirations
for now while the movie implies that the
scene of Thanos his contentment comes
immediately after he wipes out half of
all life
it's not necessarily true could the
scene actually be a sneak preview of the
ending of next year's Avengers movie
giving fans an early look at Dan OSes
retirement only a year to find out
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]